could I ask you to take your seats I'd
like to call our meeting to order and we
will proceed to item four on our agenda
we
are in favor of supporting all of our
languages here I will be speaking in
French we have interpreting into various
languages this afternoon so you can find
which language you can listen to so
please use them
so this afternoon we have interpreting
an English French German Italian Dutch
Greek Spanish Portuguese Swedish
Hungarian polish Romanian and we also
have interpreting into Arabic
and you can find the channel that you
would like to use
post it around the rooms that will help
you then to follow along with our debate
this afternoon
first of all I would really like to
warmly welcome a group of 15 young women
and men from Bahrain they are between 15
and 26 years of age
they are currently conducting a study
visit in Brussels within the European
institutions as part of the sixth
edition of the project young
parliamentarians please
feel welcome throughout the course of
this entire discussion and
I'd like to invite you all to stay with
us throughout the course of the
afternoon welcome to the subcommittee on
human rights I see that there are a lot
of young women I am a feminist
keep that in mind so I'd like to thank
all of these young women for being with
us this afternoon
now in a few days time as you all know
at least if you're at all interested in
football that's not actually my case
I am much more interested in human
rights than I am in football having said
that today we are going to have to deal
with both both of those issues looking
at football and human rights and we will
therefore be talking about the World Cup
of football 2022 in Qatar now Qatar was
awarded the World Cup in 2010
and since that point in time a number of
Human Rights organizations have spoken
out against the conditions
the working conditions of foreign
workers who were recruited to build the
stadiums in Qatar in fact the European
Parliament adopted a resolution in 2013
to express a number of concerns
related to this
specifically as pertains to the labor
rights and the protections that Qatar
should have now
various human rights organizations and
diplomatic diplomatic missions in DOA
have indicated that thousands of foreign
workers have died on the construction
sites as a result of the
building of stadia
now there are also reports of
discrimination amongst nationalities as
well as work-related accidents that were
not covered
in terms of medical care or because of
workers compensation or insurance cover
and be in Qatar Now activity reports of
the ILO
have outlined that progress has been
made and that challenges remain in terms
of the implementation of qatar's Labor
reforms one of the most decisive reforms
current and that's been supported by the
International Community community was
the end of
mandatory sponsoring which is known of
known as kafala a system in the country
so this would would mean that workers
would be able to have the freedom to
change employer to be protected
as well as to be able to maintain
control of their ID
papers extremely important
now we hope that we will be able to have
a Frank an open Dialogue on all of these
aspects of this issue today in this
exchange of views I think that's how we
are better able to understand everything
and look at what reforms can be
expanded on and implemented it also
seems important to me that if we
consider
how typical this topical this issue is
we've seen that the country is under
great scrutiny right now and I'd like to
thank all of the organizations for their
work but once this is less topical once
the world has moved on the lights are
out on the World Cup
all of the work that has begun in Qatar
to uphold
labor rights I hope that work will
continue
after this point so I'd like to thank
the ILO we work
regularly with the ILO
and we hope that they will continue to
support a number of reforms they've
already been working on them in the
country in Qatar and more generally
in that peninsula
were
really pointing the finger at Qatar
today in terms of a lack of Human Rights
but what we've seen is that this is a
reality not just in Qatar but in many
countries in the region and therefore
it's of utmost importance for our work
to continue to serve the purpose of
advancing human rights men and women's
rights workers rights and labor rights
within the context of sporting events
but more generally
in the context of
all events now we've noted for example
recently in the cop 27 in Egypt we've
seen issues with human rights so it's so
dramatic in the country
with Abdullah
who is
on Hunter strike hunger strike in the
country and we haven't heard about
possible freeing of him so we have to
continue to improve the situation of
Human Rights around the world
now we thank the minister of Labor from
the state of Qatar Mr al-marie for being
here this afternoon thank you for
accepting our invitation it's really
important to point this out because not
all ministers except to come so I'd like
to thank him for being here in person
today so that we can have this really
Frank and open debate
I should also like to thank Mr Max
Junior for being here he is head of the
international Labor organized
organization in DOA
um as well as Mr good
Olga Lee who Secretary General of the
International Trade union and minky
Warden who is a director of global
initiatives at Human Rights Watch I'd
like to give the floor first and
foremost to Hannah Newman who is the
chair of delegate of the delegation for
relations with their Peninsula you have
three minutes to speak go ahead sure and
I'm happy we are having this discussion
today because it clearly shows that if
you apply to be in the international
Spotlight by hosting such an
international sports event well you are
in the international Spotlight not just
about how beautiful your country is or
how good you are as a host but also
about for example your carbon footprint
and the human rights situation in the
country and I'm very happy that we're
discussing this here today in the human
rights committee
and I think the case of cortar clearly
shows that once there is a pressure on
human rights we can also see steps ahead
um in terms of the migrant workers
rights there is there are better laws on
migrants workers right and there is
since recently a minimum wage for
migrant workers in Qatar and we have a
central complaints mechanism and you
started compensation for some of the
workers many will say it comes too late
and those that are dead are dead yet it
is also part of the truth that we see
some improvements and Mr almari well
first that you are here and second that
you have been the head of the human
rights organization the national one and
became now minister of Labor I think is
a clear political sign of where at least
the Qatar leadership wants things to go
yet our assessment is that we still need
to work
continue working together first of all
to fully implement the laws because
there are many people who employ people
in Qatar that are not a big fan of the
end of the kafala system
um so a lot of problems continue to fill
gaps in the reforms especially when it
comes to domestic workers and to
increase the pressure on those in the
country that do not fully comply with
the new rules and we have a big hope and
we will continue watching to make sure
that when the spotlight moves on so when
the World Cup is over the reforms in
Qatar continue at the same speed Mr
Murray will have all our support on that
one and also to see whether culture will
manage to become a bit of a
um well a bit of an encouragement to
other GCC countries and other countries
that still have the kafala system in the
region also when it comes to
compensation I think and the World Cup
itself really needs a symbol to clearly
show that compensation will go beyond
what you and we have and and also maybe
some kind of an apology for things that
went wrong in the past
but in total I mean things have changed
in Qatar this just leaves me to one last
point I really hope that the people who
will come to Qatar for the football
World Cup no matter what their sexuality
orientation is will have the chance to
let's say um show their affection to
each other as openly as they would show
their affection to sports and to
football especially
thank you Anna Michelle minister
if you allow
you know that I don't always follow
protocol to the T
so if you would allow I should like to
give the floor to minky Warden who's
director of the global initiatives at
Human Rights Watch I know that we
usually start with the minister I was
minister at one time and I remember that
when it comes to protocol usually we try
to get our word in first but I'd like to
just be a bit creative here in the
subcommittee of Human Rights and give
the floor to our experts first because I
think it's good for us to lay the
backdrop here
as to what we have experienced over
recent years
within that context I think that all the
work that the experts has done has have
has have done is really important so to
start the debate I'd like to ask
everyone to stick to Six Minutes of
speaking time that way we'll be able to
have your presentations yes but also a
debate with the members that are here
and it will leave enough time for a
question and answers session minky the
floor is yours for six minutes to start
if you agree thank you very much
foreign
sport this year opened with the Winter
Olympics in Beijing while the Chinese
government was committing crimes against
humanity
then the most recent football World Cup
host Russia invaded Ukraine
the year will end with qatar's World Cup
where the spotlight will fall as it
should on wage theft and unexplained
deaths of thousands of Migrant workers
who built the infrastructure for
football's Flagship event
FIFA granted Qatar the World Cup
tournament in 2010 with no human rights
due diligence FIFA set no conditions
about protections for the migrant
workers who would be needed to build the
massive infrastructure for the
tournament FIFA also failed to examine
the human rights concerns for
journalists or discrimination that LGBT
people women and others face in Qatar
in 2016 FIFA adopted the UN guiding
principles on business and human rights
and in 2017 FIFA passed a human rights
policy
today's discussion is focused on labor
but all human rights are interconnected
qatar's lack of protections for migrant
workers press Freedom women's rights
LGBT rights and the country's lack of
Remedy including there are no unions and
striking is not allowed for migrant
workers
and the absence of independent human
rights institutions created conditions
where serious abuses occurred during the
12 years of World Cup preparation
I will address these abuses and
acknowledge some very important steps
that have been taken by Qatari
authorities and the labor Ministry I
will also need to highlight how
unfortunately these reforms remain
insufficient to fully prevent further
abuses and to provide remedy for those
abuses that have occurred and above all
to further encourage Qatari authorities
and FIFA to improve human rights and
labor rights going forward
in Qatar the male guardianship system
rules deny women the right to make key
decisions about their lives migrant
domestic workers can be confined to
their employer's home and may be subject
to physical and sexual abuse
on LGBT rights qatar's Penal Code
article 285 punishes consensual sexual
relations between men with up to seven
years in prison in October Human Rights
Watch published new research that Qatar
had arbitrarily arrested six Qatari LGBT
people and subjected them to beatings
sexual harassment and attention just
last week Khalid solman a 2022 FIFA
World Cup Ambassador described
homosexuality as damage in the mind
Suggestions by officials that Qatar
would make an exception to its abusive
laws and practices for Outsiders are an
implicit reminder that Qatari
authorities do not believe LGBT citizens
and residents including migrant workers
deserve these basic rights
laws in Qatar restrict press freedom and
were not reformed as expected in the
run-up to the world cup instead new laws
were passed that restricted free speech
further some International journalists
have been detained while reporting ahead
of the World Cup and Qatar forced to
confess and their work has been
destroyed these unacceptable violations
of promised press Freedom were often
tied to reporting on poor living or
working conditions for migrant workers
on the World Cup infrastructure and
today Human Rights Watch is publishing a
new report that is for reporters who
will go to Qatar to cover the World Cup
this month the Supreme committee for
delivery and Legacy has told Human
Rights Watch it will provide shelters
and Clinics for victims of abuse during
the World Cup including migrant workers
FIFA has given similar assurances and
these are important steps forward
on labor reforms in Qatar Qatar has
introduced several promising reforms
over the years especially after 2017
when it committed to technical
cooperation in an agreement with the ILO
because of the ILO forced labor
complaint in 2014. but these reforms
have been Limited in their impact due to
their late introduction narrow scope or
gaps in implementation
Human Rights Watch and migrant groups
continue to document abuses including
wage abuses illegal recruitment fees as
well as deaths that continue to be
uninvestigated and uncompensated
Qatari authorities have failed to
investigate the deaths of thousands of
Migrant workers with a large number of
which are attributed to so-called
natural causes
most tragically in these cases under
Qatari labor law families do not receive
any compensation
the controversy around the number of
deaths has received the most attention
but a big concern for Human Rights Watch
is the high share of unexplained and
uncompensated deaths
Human Rights Watch recently interviewed
Ram pukar sahani whose father died in
Qatar this year
his father died at a construction work
site in his work uniform and there is a
photo to verify this tragic case
even then his death was reported to be a
cardiac arrest a natural cause with no
investigation into its actual causes
thus it was considered non-work related
and his family has not been compensated
I'm sorry that migrant workers and the
families of workers who died cannot be
with us today to tell you about the
economic hardship that leads them to
send beloved family members away for
years and the trauma when they don't
return home alive
the Supreme committee has started
encouraging its contractors to adopt
life insurance for migrant workers which
provides compensation regardless of the
place or injuries of death but this
program only began in 2019 applies only
to their contractors and because it is
not mandatory it has been adopted by
only 23 contractors
FIFA and Qatar committing to a remedy
fund is not at all at odds with
acknowledging the important reforms made
by Qatar especially in the last three
years Human Rights Watch Amnesty
International and a large Global
Coalition of fans labor groups human
rights groups are asking FIFA and Qatar
to remedy these abuses by providing
financial compensation to workers and
their families and to set up a migrant
worker Center
thank you very much leaving a positive
Legacy in Qatar after the World Cup
includes both continuing the momentum
that is already present with labor
reforms and compensating those who work
to deliver the World Cups before the
labor reforms Minister almari and the
ILO will present today
any discussion of legacy is questionable
without retroactive compensation thank
you
thank you minky I give now the flow to
Max Junior a head of Office of the ILO
in Qatar hindua you have the floor six
minutes thank you very much chair and
thank you very much for the opportunity
to be here to share our perspectives
from the ILO project office in Doha
um as has been mentioned we've been
working in Qatar for the past four and a
half years on a comprehensive program of
work that was agreed between the
government and the ILO and negotiated
with the International Trade union
Confederation and the international
organization of employers
I'll be sharing some of the progress
made over the past four years some of
the challenges and also some Reflections
and I hope that we can provide some
nuance and context on a debate that is
often missing Shades of Gray
in the past four years we've seen
tangible progress major developments in
terms of new laws and policies the
establishments of new institutions or
the enhancement of existing institutions
to ensure more effective implementation
of these laws and policies we've seen
increased Partnerships and engagements
with different stakeholders in Qatar and
internationally including with the
international trade unions
we've heard already from some of the
opening remarks about the changes to the
kafala system I would I agree with what
minky said that there are gaps in
implementation but I would disagree in
saying that they are narrow in scope
that these reforms are narrower in scope
in the two years since these changes to
the kafala system were introduced 350
000 workers have changed jobs that's a
significant proportion of the overall
labor force
when we talk about the minimum wage when
it was introduced 280 000 workers so
their wages increase that's 13 of the
workforce when we talk about the
legislation on occupational heat stress
protecting outdoor workers it's reduced
the number of workers who have been
exposed to heat Related Disorders so
obviously there are still gaps in
implementation but this has had a
concrete impact on the lives of hundreds
of thousands
I want to focus on two main uh reforms
one relates to heat stress obviously one
of the main occupational hazards for
workers in Qatar
in 2019 the minister of Labor the
Supreme committee and the ILO
commissioned the world's largest ever
study on the impact of heat on Workers
Health
and we tested various strategies on how
to mitigate heat stress this was carried
out by a team of experts from the
University of thessaly in Greece
This research helped to inform new
legislation adopted in 2021 which
extends the window in which outdoor work
is prohibited so from 10 AM to 3 30 PM
from the 1st of June to the 15th of
September all outdoor work is prohibited
in addition to that there is a threshold
at which all work must stop regardless
of the time of day or time of year
in addition there are
more protections for example all outdoor
workers must undergo annual Health
screenings Etc
we've seen that this is
probably the most Progressive
legislation on heat stress in the world
and
sorry okay sorry
um we feel that this is probably the
most Progressive legislation on heat
stress in the world and we have already
some indication that it's making a
direct impact on Workers Health
we track the number of patients admitted
to clinics with heat Related Disorders
each summer
and we saw that this summer there were
351 patients admitted with heat Related
Disorders
prior to the introduction of the new
legislation in 2019 and 2020 there were
1300 and 1500 workers admitted so
there's been a steep decline 77 percent
decline in the proportion of workers
admitted with heat-related disorders
this is the impact of the reforms
it's also worth spending some time on
the issue of social dialogue as was
mentioned Qatar law does not allow
foreign workers to form or join trade
unions however legislation adopted in
2019 allows for elected migrant worker
representatives in worker management
committees at the Enterprise level
a first for the Gulf region
the joint committees are similar to The
Works councils in Europe and this is an
important first step towards promoting
workers voice and workers representation
gradual approach is supported by the
international trade unions from the
beginning the ituc and Global Union
federations BWI idwf ITF and uni Global
have been a key part of the reform
agenda
they have held meetings every six months
with the government of Qatar and the ILO
to review progress and set priorities
going forward
and in addition to that strategic
strategic level engagement the global
unions have staff on the ground in Doha
also a first for the region
I see that I've already four and a half
minutes in so I'm gonna skip a few parts
and I think this this um
you know really to touch on a broader
Point here it's not only what has been
achieved and what has been adopted in
terms of legislation or new systems but
how it's been achieved
um with close engagement with the
International Community not only the ILO
and the international trade unions but
also in dialogue with International ngos
also with ngos from across Asia
including migrant Forum Asia huge
Coalition of ngos in in that region
and also exchanging expertise with
several European States including
through mousse that have been signed
with Sweden France and that are in the
pipeline with the Netherlands and
Belgium
now onto some of the gaps and priorities
I think there is universal recognition
that there are gaps in the
implementation of the labor reforms this
is not surprising given their magnitude
it takes time to build institutions it
takes time to change mindsets and to
change business practices that have been
deeply entrenched let me highlight three
key priorities for us
one is the full implementation of the
kafala reforms there are still workers
who are struggling to change jobs
whether that's through lack of knowledge
on the procedures or sometimes through
employers who are retaliating against
them when they try to change jobs
there is the issue to of wage payments
now there are better systems for workers
to Lodge complaints in the last 12
months 34 000 workers launch complaints
mostly on through an online online
platform they can do also Lodge
complaints anonymously
and there are new labor courts that have
been established but still it can take
months for workers to receive their
their due wages and the third priority
is the to make sure that domestic
workers can also fully benefit from
these reforms uh especially when it
comes to the issue of working time and
the right for domestic workers to take
at least one day off per week
we are all impatient to see the reforms
fully applied and enforced but we also
recognize that changes of this scale
take time and we can reflect on how 10
tangible progress has been made in the
past four or five years
earlier this year we commissioned a
survey with the research institute among
a thousand plus migrant workers low-wage
migrant workers and the workers
themselves 86 percent of them said that
the reforms have made a positive impact
on their lives
now looking forward everybody recognizes
that the World Cup is not the Finishing
Line we will continue to work with the
government with workers and employers to
further Advance the reforms in the
coming years and further support the
alignment of qatar's Law and practice
with International labor standards thank
you very much thank you I give another
floor
of the Deputy Secretary General of the
International Trade union Confederation
I'll just first let me lean very
strongly on the point that Max has made
because as ituc uh we were part of this
whole process from the beginning first
to us we put on record in 2014 we were
the one that took Qatar to the hello to
make the point that we need this reform
to happen
and let's also put it on um on record
that indeed as trade unions we see
ourselves as Oliver Twist uh sometimes
we like what we see
but it's not enough we want to go back
and ask for more and first you say what
we see they are commendable they reform
to the kafala system we appreciate it
the the the minimum wage
everyone collects a minimum wage and
clearly we we always make the argument
that wages should not be inserted in
competition and so when you have minimum
with just one way of taking wage out of
competition so we are excited about it
we're excited about the occupational
health and safety reforms that have been
made by Qatar which is contributing to
the reduction of dates in February this
year a delegation of trade unions from
Africa visited Qatar
we visited and we spoke to quite a
number of Migrant workers especially our
brothers and sisters Africans are in
large population working in Qatar and
they gave us uh their uh
stories and what came out in the summary
of it is that they have seen remarkable
improvement from what it was before and
what is it it is uh today as trade
unions who wanted to see reform in Qatar
we are concerned and interested in
consolidating the gains that have been
made uh in recent time we begin to see
a moment of report that tends to want to
put the gains we have made in Jeopardy
and we think if this is not halted it's
not going to do us any good importantly
um they're beginning to be a narrative
that is you know swelling that tends to
say these old criticism is not about the
migrant workers it's not about improving
situation first it's about pursuing
Vendetta and then also you can see that
it's also about
cropping up racism I'm an African I know
what it is when you talk about racism uh
institutional historical and if you have
that and that begins to um uh have a
space and a dominance in the process
then clearly you are going to decapitate
the gains that have been made uh we want
to really put that on record that that
needs to uh to change and it's more
worrisome especially when uh especially
before we visited we had about 6 000
something dead we were very strong when
we visited Qatar and we visited uilo
office and we spoke to the people the
figures don't match reality that have
been put in the in that point but why
not taking issues with those who have uh
put the figure out we encourage the
office can you try to do in course of
this work show the reality and we think
the ILO has also done that a bit but we
see a culture of doubling down
uh even when you provide the information
people then move to this information to
double down and when you have that for
us our concern is that how these gains
then become a problem and when we say
this consciously because
we're talking about the Middle East that
does not have you excuse me and The
Honorable Minister you excuse me the
culture of democracy is different in the
Middle East it's a society that is
monarchical largely and if you want to
force a change that's a gradualist
approach that also works when people
have made concession encourage them push
them further don't scandalize the
process as if nothing has happened
nothing has been done that brings a bit
of problem yes as trade unions we have
concern too of certain things we want to
see change
we we think as trade unions you cannot
defend workers rights if there are no
trade unions
so uh the good thing we see is that
workers representative can sue one step
in the right direction we want to
encourage Qatar can we move to the
formation of trade unions uh uh uh
gradually that's something we want to
see on the issue of which shift we have
seen Improvement in using electronic
means to pay salaries and all of that
but we still think there is a need for
better supervision of the process
because certain persons are simply are
falling off then also that is the issue
of a family reunion when we visited our
people there including Asians we saw
that the arrangement can benefit the
workers moram and you know well-being
can improve so sexually if there is some
provision for our family reunion lastly
and uh now how we pause here to see what
the ILO is doing is something we want to
seriously encourage
the idea of working with Qatar through a
social dialogue process we're happy I
said today our trade unions are on the
ground in Qatar offices organizing
representing workers work you know
trying to improve the situation on the
ground
we hope and we wish we can see this in
the United Arab Emirates we hope we wish
we can see this in Saudi Arabia because
for us these are bigger economies in the
Middle East you do not want to force
water from the uh from the uh from the
valley to the hill it is better if the
water is stroking down from the hill
down to the valley this bigger economy
should come to the plate and we hope
that this committee can help us to do
that and if we have a situation where
the attack uh is just uh about chipping
away at the gains that have been made
our fear is that these bigger economies
that we are we are targeting might get
scared and say oh if you can do that to
Qatar then don't come near me so the
idea is how do we push everybody in a
supportive encouraging uh manner of
course when we need to bring up the
stick we should do so but it should be
in a sense to improve on this situation
I thank you chair minister
I'll give you the floor Minister for
labor in Qatar you were president of the
Human Rights Commission in Qatar and I
know that you are very keen on the uh
human rights issues as former president
but I know also that your fight within
the government and within Qatari Society
is not easy I think we need to underline
that
along with what's just been said the
fact that our aim is to support
efforts that can be made that are being
made that must be made
that have been made in this area
so I'll give you the floor now I don't
know whether you'll be speaking English
or Arabic please let us know so that
people can choose their Channel
and put our headphones on thank you
[Music]
first of all I would like thank you very
much your Excellency
for this invitation and for this very
important discussion and really I would
like to thank uh the chair of darb about
their interventions and our colleague
from the Human Rights Watch and ILO and
ituc Africa and I would like from you
really I'm a prepare my uh my uh my
speech in English but I will transfer to
speak Arabic if you allow me for that I
think a few everybody to transfer for
the Arabic language
uh be diet and
to begin with
before I became labor minister
I worked for about 18 years in the field
of Human Rights and I was an activist in
human rights and
in the last 10 years I was also heading
the national human rights committee in
Qatar and I was also the general
secretary
of the International Alliance for human
rights societies worldwide so I do know
the role of the human rights activists
and I do realize what are the challenges
regarding human rights whether they are
in our countries in the Arab countries
in Qatar specifically or in other uh
countries worldwide
whether they are in Europe or elsewhere
and to be honest with you
when I was heading the national human
rights committee in Qatar there has been
many recommendations and many criticism
that I formulated myself against the
government in my country and this is
exactly what my colleagues have just
done now
however
being in my capacity of Labor minister
of course this is very helpful in me
pushing forward this agenda and these
reforms to make them materialize in
actual facts
as
my
colleagues have spoken about the reforms
indeed if there are
reforms that have been started we had
many challenges there has been many
recommendations
that
were
articulated but not implemented and the
colleagues from the ILO from the ituc
they did say that there are
uh reforms but these reforms face
obstacles there were there are a number
of reforms that have been requested we
started on the journey
sometimes we say that reforms are
enacted but implementation is lacking
and but we do confirm I do confirm that
there are a string of reforms and there
is a series of initiatives to implement
them in the field however
there are gaps indeed facing these
reforms and their implementation
specifically other reforms have been
undertaken a very short span of time so
I mean this is only natural that we Face
difficulties and this is what my ILO has
said my colleague he said that's
question of mindset as well I mean
nobody can say suffice to enact laws
that they happen I mean you need to
change the atmosphere the environment
and the mindset and we are continuing
such efforts now
from the start Qatar has already been an
Open Country I mean we have the police
of open doors to all those who want to
visit there has been always channels of
communication between Qatar and the
other stakeholders Qatar
is among the few countries that open the
door to door to to some to some
organizations such as Human Rights Watch
for example so we uh there has there are
about 17 agreements between in 2017 that
was an agreement between the ILO and our
country and there is a serious
discussion between Qatar and
international trade unions as well these
International Trade union Federation
Confederation for example have been a
consultative body to us we have always
been welcoming positive constructive
criticism however
International organizations always
wonder I mean if these reforms are only
linked to the run-up to the World Cup or
will they be continuing afterwards once
the spotlights are uh shut down so I can
tell you that the reforms in the
pipeline are based on the Qatar vision
of 2030. this vision
does State clearly that there needs to
be reforms
connected to the topics at issue at hand
the World Cup obviously had sped up
somehow but these reforms are not linked
it's not the reason I mean the reason
for that is not the World Cup but it is
part and parcel of the vision 2030. in
October last October there was a meeting
I met all the International federations
in Qatar and called it from ILO were
present Human Rights was also
participating in other ngos and we
spoke about our vision post World Cup
last week I was in Geneva and I had a
meeting with the and the ILO uh General
director that meeting aimed at
continuing cooperation and projects post
World Cup under discussions underway
as we speak
to make sure
that the ILO office in Doha is now
provisional and there are discussions to
make it a standing Office of the ILO in
Doha so we are also all aiming at
setting up what we call the dialogue of
Doha on an annual basis specifically
talk about the migrant workers and
related items from migrant workers from
Africa so that is going cooperation that
is going to be a standing annual channel
of communication and all this indicate
that these reforms will continue post
World Cup and it is titling to the
vision of Qatar 2030.
all the speakers have said that there
are reforms
now we look at to the compensations or
the remedies
to compensate the victims and the is an
ethical Duty before being a statutory or
legal
aspect so there are views views are
different
some ngos said that we should have a
remedy fund
uh for to compensate victims we are
against this initiative
and creating a new mechanism because the
legal framework in Qatar today does
state for
uh funds in 2018 composition fund has
been created and we have paid
350 million dollars so far in the last
period as compensation the remedies and
therefore we are not against remedies
and compensating there are mechanisms
and from this very restroom we call upon
all the
unions human rights organization if they
have names of victims of workers who
have not been compensated what we do
have the the fund
and we are completely ready to
compensate and to make up for the loss
for the loss and therefore from this
restaurant we really call upon any of
you to question me well obviously time
is running out and Miss Maria I will try
to speak us in a summary
my colleague from ituc has said that
that we do not want to close the door to
constructive criticism absolutely not
however there should not be any
politicizing I mean using some
misinformation uh specifically of
figures of the victims of the deaths so
we've spoken about fifteen thousand ten
thousand uh so these are inaccurate
figures and therefore we call upon the
specialist to refer to the a genuine
sources which is the ILO and the ituc
my colleague has spoke about
discrimination what we do except uh
specifically any criticism is welcome
somebody spoke about racism and and hate
speech obviously such narrative is not
going to favor the continuation of the
reforms there are some media
unfortunately
who said that the the qataris
are a bunch of the Qatari Nationals are
a bunch of
criminals of terrorists I mean how can
we accept such Narrative of hatred
speech hatred speech and also this
racism that is obviously it's a name and
shame basically against us and based on
this we do
call upon all these organizations all
human rights to condemn to denounce such
campaign smear campaigns against our
country so we have to be fair in
condemning all sides
so this is basically what I wanted to
say in a nutshell however if there are
any specific questions I am ready to
reply thank you very much
thank you very much Minister I'll give
the floor straight to my colleagues we
have a lot of names on the list so I'm
going to ask you to stick to the time
one minute only so Peter Vandal for the
Epp first
thank you very much
while the world football championship
2022 should never have ended up in Qatar
we know
what um workers rights are like in the
Qatar how many that hundreds of people
have died and that only confirms my
opinion it should never have gone there
there's a huge amount of Corruption of
course in who gets the World Cup
the 16
people involved in the FIFA decision
have been
linked to corruption Mr platini for
instance also apparently did everything
he could to ensure
that French support
was received
so
in practice
is their
really no forced labor anymore
um
I'm wondering if it's still going on my
question to the minister if
you will
allow it why don't you allow European
inspections let's see that allow us to
monitor you
the new situation also thank you Peter
Andrea one minute
thank you very much thank you for this
opportunity
well I have some football principles
that leads me to question the World Cup
because we know that in 2020 Italy won't
be there and my my team Naples is not
playing as well as I'd like to see them
but joking aside
coming back to the principles labor
dialogue aside from that there are no
initiatives
ongoing nationally speaking in the
run-up to the World Cup but there is
this a social dialogue with the
international
uh organizations and with the trade
unions Etc we need to encourage this we
need to encourage this program of of
reforms
and it would be a real shame with the
World Cup coming up for us in this
institution in the European Parliament
if we were to erect barriers to these
types of undertakings so we really
should encourage this program have more
clarity on the data that's important
specifically on three subjects that
we are focusing on working conditions
the
issue of wages and finally to make sure
that we have a stronger Trade union
presidents in the country so finally
this is the question how can we get the
EP and more involved in the negotiations
that the minister referred to so not
just International
institutions not International
organizations but also the EP thanking
you
yes thank you very much
um I definitely see the reforms
um being made
to improve the working conditions
um such as the introduction of a minimum
wage or loss that limit working hours in
extreme heat but it's clearly not enough
um I am familiar with some of your
comments being made in different
interviews I know that you have
objection when it comes to the fund I
know that you're even asking where are
the victims do you have names of the
victims I know that you speak about
certain racist motivations
and I know that you also mention it as
for example publicity stunt but this is
of course about guaranteeing human
rights and the fundamental rights of
people and what I would seriously like
to know from the minister is how will
your government ensure that the rights
of lgbti plus people but also women
are guaranteed so how will you protect
their rights because as you know there
is a structural problem there is an
issue with guaranteeing these
fundamental rights of women in lgbti
plus uh people so what are you going to
do about it concretely thank you thank
you
for the greens
president
thank you chair firstly
greetings to the families of the victims
the um
laborers who have died for because of
money because of corruption because of
FIFA's decisions
who wanted to hold the World Cup in
Qatar whatever happened despite the fact
that human rights are not respected they
died through exploitation because there
are conditions of slavery as the uh
human rights organization
Representatives said and I wonder what
is the position of the eeas
we don't have a representative of the
FIFA here either they should be here to
provide explanations not just yourselves
the Qatari government and the ngos it's
FIFA who is primarily responsible for
having laundered this whole situation
and it's sad
because
when it comes right down to it football
buys anything corruption can buy
anything
but you won't buy us or the memories of
the victims
Miguel Urban Crespo
thank you chairman last week we heard
that FIFA
has banned the Danish team from training
in Qatar with a t-shirt that said human
rights for all because they believe this
is a political message and that is
banned so holding a football World Cup
in a country
which uh
whose rules run counter to 20 of the 30
un rights human rights standards
Qatar believes that women are unhuman uh
being beings under the protection of men
and that homosexuality merits prison
they also ban
trades unions and political parties
and we're seeing an example of how these
large events particularly sports events
are used to launder the image of uh
certain countries we are talking about a
World Cup which has been bathed in Blood
and that's a political message which for
many and for many of us this will be a
World Cup of shame we express our
solidarity with women with LGBT uh plus
people and I therefore have to express
my support for the boycott of the World
Cup Costas is
many people lost their lives have been
wounded 90 percent of the work done on
the World Cup uh infrastructure was done
by migrant workers we're talking about
business worth millions of Euros
um with a
FIFA and so on the
strikes And Trades Union organizations
are banned
and the labor minister is we hear a
former member of an NGO
the European Union's attitude actually
is hypocritical
it's very
positive that many sports people and
supporters
are
expressing their uh opposition to this
situation families
or victims must be compensated they
should be compensated this is
the
only way forward to protect rights and
freedoms
[Music]
so we have additional speakers from
other groups larivoters
thank you Marie
um I do think this is the World Cup of
Shame and I think it's good that it got
said whenever I see a football pitch it
always strikes me how small a football
pitch is
um and I find the contrast so huge
between the smallness of the pitch and
the huge suffering and Corruption that
such a pitch can instigate what we're
doing here today is truth seeking I
suppose I read newspapers I watch
documentary I attend meetings like this
where I come down on things all things
considered is
um are things better yes they are are
things good no absolutely not and I see
two structural problems one problem is I
think that the Qatari government is very
keen on reaping the financial and
reputational benefits of this world cup
and that the International Community can
provide via This World Cup
but the other side of the metal here the
other side of those benefits is the
scrutiny that the International
Community
unleashes for such a World Cup and it is
right scrutiny or to rightly so that
we're doing that and I see extreme
reluctance on this scrutiny and I want
to say you cannot have one without the
other the second is from a U.N report
yes now the uren a special rapporteur on
uh racism racial discrimination
xenophobia said described in 2020 Qatar
in Qatar a de facto system based on
national origin I'll wrap up soon which
results in structural discrimination and
coming from that I think that yes things
are a lot better but I want to make sure
that that marking point is taken into
account I have a sorry sorry I I can't
because we have other people wanted to
have the floor so our corn can we do a
second round with our questions yep
the detainees of the arrest uh in August
of 2022. yeah yeah so we go we go to the
next one so
um Jose Ramon pause
thank you madam chairman
thank you to all those who are here on
the podium particularly the minister for
his background and because he's
responsible for the area of Labor in
Qatar the most recent reports of the
international labor organization which
is the specialist un organization on
this are positive
and say that there has been significant
progress as our speakers said and I want
to highlight the fact that the Qatar
World Cup is a good example of sports
diplomacy look at the region countries
which months ago
uh a year ago were blocking things
they're now cooperating together
and there are things that the Parliament
can bring the Abraham Accords and and
blockages on that and so on we are
actually
getting significant progress with the
commission and the GCC Council we have a
recent visit from high Representatives
of the EU and I think in the European
Parliament we should just stop always
blocking an open paths forward for
dialogue because if we get in our own
way like this we won't progress and
we'll be a poor example from the
countries in the for the countries in
the region thank you uh
we talked about the definition
um of forms and what we mean and the
changes everything has uh all of this is
welcome but what's happening as far as
I'm concerned is
um those guest workers those migrants
who went to Qatar for a better life and
then ended up dead
um let's remember them we're talking
about compensation we have a moral
obligation to compensate the families
that we should have actually compensated
them if they had not died and my
question is how can we guarantee that
compensation will actually be paid how
Minister can we
ensure this can we rely on this
how can all of us here including the
sports groups and the political
responsibilities answer this thank you
thank you for your minutes uh did Marcus
there
thank you very much
since I'm nine years old I always
watched the men's FIFA World Cup it was
always a highlight for me as a football
fan but how can I enjoy watching a
football match in a stadium which was
built on the life of Migrant workers and
under unhuman working conditions I'm
really fed up with this kind of Mafia
organization called FIFA so it is
impossible to watch these smart matches
with joy I will refrain from watching at
least
put in 500 migrant workers died since
Carter was named the host of for the
men's FIFA World Cup
Qatar promised to improve the working
conditions and as we heard there were
made some progress but not enough has
been made and so what can be done that
labor migrants and their families
receive full and adequate reparations
really can you promise that this will
happen for the migrant workers this
would be a very important sign thank you
thank you Alessandra Moretti
uh
microphone
English so you have to go to English no
no no it's fine English is on the
English Channel is on
Grand
so it should be a major megaphone but
also we should use the same method today
the cop 27 is in Egypt
in Italy we have not received any
information on your genie and what his
outcome was or any reassurance about the
procedure and when it comes to working
conditions
um in Italy we know that we've had a
number of deaths in Italy alone in this
context Italy being a European country
we should be hard on Qatar when we ask
them to respect human rights and labor
rights but we must also make sure defend
it when they're making progress compared
to other countries a question minister
the Ambassador who spoke on homosexuals
stating that it is an illness I think
that
you should take a stringent position on
this a penalty even so that you can make
clear the road that you are willing to
take on this subject
one minute I'm going to cut you off if
you go longer
thank you well I'll be brief I didn't
really intend to take the floor but
listen to the colleagues I was thinking
what Mr odigie said
I think we should support him of course
lots of colleagues
you know
2014 2018 we didn't have all of this
when we were talking about uh Sochi or
Beijing or when the World Cup went there
um
I think there's a 10 an image that's our
picture that's 10 years old
the only resolution was in in the
parliament was 2012 when we looked at
the difficult situation of deplorable
conditions for workers in some cases and
since then reforms have been undertaken
and the situation uh was no longer a
preparation for us so what I'm saying
today is that if you look at an old
picture 10 years ago we need to actually
respect uh the journey in what's
happened since then thank you
president so I am going to ask a
question to the minister
he said that a number of European
companies today are in Qatar and they
are not respecting the rules established
in Qatar can you quote the name of these
I know that there are 11 I'd like to
know if you could tell us the names of
those European companies who are not
ascribing to the minimum regulation set
done by Qatar Minister the floor is
yours
and
first of all I'd like to uh just say how
happy I am to hear all those uh
interventions on Qatar is with and for
constructive criticism without
constructive criticism would have never
been able to achieve this uh these big
big waveforms you've put long questions
before answering all of them I'd
I'd like to address those who call for
the boycott of
the Qatari World Cup so my question have
you ever boycotted any
previous iterations of the word cup
in the past why do you focus only on the
one that is organized in Qatar so this
is this is my question to you have you
have you watched all of the previous
iterations or not so I'm here talking
about just the previous one in 2018 for
example
your questions you spoke
or many of you spoke about
the different sexual orientations
so here uh as a representative of the
Qatari government I'm not here to judge
upon
each and everyone's sexual orientations
I just would like to confirm that each
and every one of you is welcomed in
Qatar to attend
the mattress this is the highest level
communication from the chief of state in
Qatar so this is a very clear answer to
those questions
now talking about compensations
for this chapter we have not
accepted
to turn a blind eye
on any victim it's painful and every
victim is painful and of course there is
a mechanism
to which everyone can Resort in order to
seek remedy and get compensation
now
on the front of numbers and the number
of
that
you have one day a newspaper talking
about 6500
victims another one ten thousand and a
third one talks about fifteen thousand
as if there were a competition between
newspapers who's gonna say
more
that I can confirm that
and this is seconded by specialized
agencies and organizations
that
if as a politician you want
the right information you should
look for
the right source of information and who
is the right source of information you
have the ILO and you have the IG igc not
to mention the fact that
ILO lodged it
a complaint against Qatar
in 2014
maybe this is a proof of integrity
and uh
talking about compensation fund or
migrant worker fund it is a mechanism I
think it's ranked seventh in the word
in terms of volume there is no such
fund for workers in the region
at that level and as I said
at least 350 million dollar
envelope has been
uh given as a compensation to workers
and to conclude I just say that we will
despite criticism
destructive
or not
carry on on the path of reforms
and of course
I can understand that some lack proper
information that's why they they speak
about boycott they speak about
violations
victims maybe they lack the proper
information so I call upon them to look
for that information from the right
source
but of course I would reiterate
each and every one is welcomed in Qatar
and I can confirm you that the Qatar
World Cup will be the best iteration
in football history thank you very much
indeed and still I'm saying that we're
ready for constructive criticism thank
you I'm going to give the floor to miss
amario
from the uh her delegation for the Arab
peninsula you have two minutes thank you
here at the back the situation of
foreign workers and the ongoing labor
reforms are key elements for the eu's
bilateral engagement with Qatar
featuring prominently nar-political and
human rights dialogue our latest the
fourth round took place on September
12th in Brussels with very positive
outcome we have welcomed the different
reforms in this regard making Qatar the
first country in the Gulf to formally
dismantle the cafe La or sponsorship
system which grants excessive powers to
the employer over the employee we have
also welcomed qatar's adoption of the
Region's first non-discriminatory
minimum wage covering all migrant
workers including domestic workers
there has been progress but challenges
remain there is a resistance to the
reforms by parts of the society and
segments of the business Community
including on part of western
multinationals operating in Qatar I
think your question was very relevant in
this regard there are gaps in
implementation despite the minimum wage
legislation and government efforts
numerous migrant workers have been have
seen their wages or work allowances
being cut or not paid at all and living
conditions of many migrant workers need
to need to be improved there is a need
for much better collection of data on
work-related fatalities and injuries
the EU continues to encourage the Qatari
authorities to improve workers living
conditions to facilitate access to
Justice to ensure payment of wages and
effective labor inspections and the EU
will continue to engage with Qatar on
these issues to help promote
sustainability of ongoing reforms in
their continuation after the World Cup
vice president hinas and commissioner
Smith discuss labor rights regularly
with Qatari leaders notably with his
Excellency Minister almari who has
visited us a number of times since his
appointment and this is in itself a sign
of sincere engagement from the Qatari
side the EU is in close contact with the
ILO office in Doha to support both
politically and technically further
labor reforms in the country and I wish
to thank Mr tunion from his team for the
great cooperation also on behalf of our
colleagues in Doha in the newly
established EU delegation to the state
of Qatar the USR for human rights Mr
Gilmer has engaged extensively on labor
rights and World Cup preparations during
his visit to Qatar in February 2020 and
through his follow-up exchanges with the
ILO office in Doha and the chair of the
national human rights committee of Qatar
the European Union will continue to
follow the human rights situation in the
country very closely through our annual
human rights and political dialogues
with the government through our newly
established EU delegation and through
the embassies of Our member states and
we stand ready to support and assist
Qatar in its human rights reform agenda
and to do our part in the common
Endeavor to make this a success story
for this country and for the rest of the
GCC beyond the World Cup thank you thank
you very much
okay I think it's frustrating for all of
us today in this debate we've just been
having but I would like to thank
minister
for taking part today it's not easy
but you've seen
the extent to which human rights and
workers rights
is important
a lot of people like football but
they're still very concerned about human
rights personally I'm not so such a fan
but
I I'm going to give everybody one minute
I'm going to cut you off at one minute
we have another important debate coming
up which is the Vania 2 initiative which
is an initiative
taken by an island that is now being
overwhelmed by climate change has been
flooded
so climate and human rights both big
issues there but please you all have one
minute I'm going to cut you off I am
going to start
with Human Rights Watch one minute
thank you very much and Minister almari
we very much respect the important role
that you had before on human rights and
that you have now and that you can still
play you ask for names and we have names
of many families of those who have died
and I wanted to say the story of ram
kushan sahani his father has uh his
father has died his son has died and he
said after my son died things have been
very difficult how will I take care of
two kids my grandchildren my wife and I
so we have many of these names we have
the the families that are trying to
survive with the lone sharks the the
worker support and Insurance Fund
correctly has compensated more than 350
million would you be prepared to extend
that retrospectively so that families of
workers who have died could claim so far
it only is about wage theft and of
course we have ex we have reported
extensively on this can we ask you to
consider to extending it retrospectively
thank you thank you I give it a photo
Max Daniel sorry
thank you very much chair
um look I think everybody knows that the
ILO works on these complex deep rooted
uh issues all over the world including
with the support of the European Union
on fundamental principles and rights at
work it's
there are no quick fixes it's always a
challenge but I think what we've seen in
Qatar is something rare we rarely see
change happening at this pace
and of course it's not finished the job
will continue but I think it's also
important to recognize the progress
so your question chair about European
companies I'm not going to name and
shame any but I will point to one um uh
intervention that has been developed
over the past few years the joint
committees these are currently voluntary
at the moment these works councils but
every conversation we have with every
company in Qatar that we meet is to
establish joint committees this is one
thing you can do to demonstrate your
commitment to the reforms and
demonstrate leadership nine times out of
ten we don't hear from those companies
again including European companies
European companies that provide those
rights for worker representation here in
Europe but don't extend those same
privileges and rights to workers in
Qatar finally there is more information
out there there's a lot of information
on our website there's a lot of data the
ministry is publishing data every month
we published an annual report which is
very comprehensive and is used by Human
Rights Watch amnesty and other ngos in
their reporting so there is more out
there for those who are interested thank
you Max thank you I give the floor to uh
Joel yeah thank you
um
a campaign is what we do
since 2010 precisely South Africa World
Cup to date we have been campaigning
around FIFA events to try to use it as
opportunity to protect rights never have
we seen
is serious International focus and this
world cup for us it's a plus we welcome
it and it accept us to advance gain but
I want to take the ways that we have
made here especially on climate change
and World Cup
27 is happening and we almost are at the
we will have been excited if human
rights has also gone in from the very
beginning uh Egypt in Africa is not we
do not have a trade Union there right
the United Arab Emirates will be hosting
cop 28. we will love this house to stay
this Focus around human rights and
climate change and using Global events
to Target human rights issues I thank
you thank you merci beaucoup thank you
very much thank you all for
participating in this debate and let me
say I'm very happy Mr falter is here
because he's in charge of the due
diligence file which is um up to
companies the companies the state
companies need to respect human rights
here and it's absolutely essential that
there be such laws and hopefully Qatar
will continue to improve companies via
and it's been inspected by due diligence
is another way of respecting human
rights and I hope that everyone
who has been very active on that matter
will continue to be so in the due
diligence debate that we will keep
happening having in the future in this
Parliament thank you